hello everyone and welcome to 2017
champions showdown in st. Louis
it's a highly anticipated event
featuring eight players nakamura is
playing the pall of quran is playing
greece your choice playing dominguez but
the match pretty much everyone is mostly
interested in is Carlson vs ding leerin
and the Tingler and managed to qualify
for the candidates in the World Cup with
Levon Aronian and also he created that
beautiful immortal game a couple of days
ago against by Jin Chi so everyone is
interested to see how he will fare
against Kingdom Magnus but it seems that
creating an immortal game against the
2500 player isn't really the same as
playing against the world champion how
does this work
Carlson and Eliran will play 30 games
they already played the first three
sections so they played four 30-minute
games
the result was two and a half to one and
a half in Carlson's favor and then they
played six 20-minute games here the
result was four and a half to one and a
half to Carlson's favor and in in these
first 10 games across and didn't lose a
single game after that they played eight
ten minute games and the result was a
six and a half to one and a half in
Carlson's favor with Carson losing only
the first game in this section so I've
seen some tweets on Twitter that Carson
is doing now to Dingley Rijn what Fisher
did tell Larson and and well pretty much
everyone everyone else in the candidates
so definitely quite a match and as I'm
making this video there will be 12 more
games of the five minutes section so you
might want to check that out as it's
live instead of watching this video so
you can watch my video later but this is
a this is one of the games this is the
last game from the 10-minute section I
kind of like this game since it's a it's
a fun game and it's a pretty poisonous
game for for a 10-minute game
so this is the one I decided to show you
Carlson has the black pieces and Dingley
Rijn plays Knight to f3
we have d5 d4 Knight to f6 c4 now 6 the
Queen
gambit declined Knight to c3 now a six
by Carlson seek after Sun d5e captors on
d5 and Bishop to g5 Bishop to e6 now III
1937 both players just developing no
action so far Bishop to d3 h6 Bishop
goes to h4 now Bishop to d6 we have
castles calls and also castles rook to
c1 a rook to e8 8 3 c6 and Bishop to g3
here we have some some action between
pieces
dinkler and offers the exchange of the
dark square bishop s-- so carson
captures we have h captures on g3 and
now Bishop to g4 Carlson doesn't want
leerin to play Knight to e5 and maybe
maybe to get f4 in so he stops this with
Bishop to g4 9th to e2 preparing that
night to come to a for capturing not the
knight on f3 doesn't really give Carson
anything if you capture G characters are
you just lost the only piece that can
oppose this beautiful light square
bishop and after moves like Bishop to b1
and queen to d3 there will be you'll
have to take care of your age 7 I mean
this entire diagonal for the entire game
and this wouldn't be very fun dr. Knight
to e2 Knight to e4 now by Carlsen Knight
to f4 and Carlsen place in 90 to f6 now
solidifying this knight on e4 Bishop to
e2 again the England wants to play
Knight to e5 so nice to d6 now he has to
allow it Knight to e5 now the exchange
of the bishops Bishop captures an e2
Queen captures any two and the night
comes to e4 leaving the other night free
to jump to c4 if needed
so okay Dingle even has a strong knight
on e5 cross it has a strong knight on e4
and if you want to keep get away from
there you do have to play f6 or f3 so G
for Carson plays Queen to g5 and it's
it's pretty good square for the Queen
you can't really kick it away from there
you can play something like Knight to h3
but Queen e7
and white didn't really achieve anything
and he did lose a lot of games so far in
the match so he doesn't want to go for
this probably so after Queen 2g v g3 and
now we have f5 and well you could
capture for maybe on f5 but if you
capture an f5 a knight captures on a5
then you constantly have to worry about
knife captures in g3 and this is no fun
in a 10 minute game so after I 5 King to
g2 we have F capture Sun g4 and here
Dingley run plays rook to h1 he doesn't
want to recapture on g4 would Knight
captures energy for it who wants to play
rook h1 rook h4 and then only then
recapture of course you can't recapture
with the Queen this losses immediately
to rook captures on e5 removing the
defender of the Queen and if you capture
you just lost the night so no point in
doing this and Knight captures and g4 is
an option but the England decided to
play rock h1 and rook aged 4 to capture
upon only then Knight to f6 rook to h4
and here
dinkler and now is threatening to
capture the g4 pawn and there this is a
very poisonous position and now Carlsen
could probably play h5 here but but this
required a lot of calculation and the
result was was nothing nothing
conclusive if you play h5 here then you
do allow Knight captures on h5 and after
Knight captures on h5 rook c2 H 1 you're
attacking this Knight now if the knight
moves this Knight is covering f7 so rook
to h8 is checkmate so if you went for
something like this after Roxy - h1
you'd have to play g6 and this is again
problematic because you get rook
captures in g4 now with a temple on the
Queen and here if you allow rook
captures and g6 you're just losing the
game so you have to play something like
rook captures on e5 but in and in here
the best move isn't actually to captured
Queen the best movies to capture the
rook with D captures on e5 now you're
still attacking the Queen but you're
also attacking the knight on d6 and
after Queen captures on e5 now you play
rook captures and g6 and after Knight to
g7 because the knight was attacked the
position is pretty equal although the
black king is kind of facing two rooks
and the Queen but you do have two nights
for a rook
if Carlson would manage to get this rook
into the game who knows who knows
everything might happen here but he's
not interested in doing anything like
this because after this route to h4 move
Carlsen plays the absolute best engine
move he plays rook captures on e5
removing the piece that was threatening
to capture the pawn on g4 he was already
up a pawn so now it's okay he's down the
exchange but he will be up to pawns D
captures on e5 Queen captures on e5 and
our rook H back to h1 Queen to e4 check
King's to g1 as the King has to protect
the rook and now Knight to c4
so Carson is up to pawns but those rooks
of Dingley aaron has aren't really doing
anything so far Queen to c2
he immediately offers the exchange of
Queens but Carson happily obliges Knight
to e5 we have a trade of Queens Knight
captures on e4 and King to g2 and
immediately rook to f8 not allowing this
night to move as the f2 pawn will fall
so rook the rook to c2
now this rook is forced to guard the f2
square
if this Knight wants to move rook to f6
now rocked d1 we have g5 kicking the
night away from there now Knight to d3
Carlsen again happily exchanges rook
captures on d3 and h5 and it's really
what do you do here is white you do have
rooks but how do you make them work so
okay
Bingley Oren finds a way before he wants
to break open on the Queen side h4 by
Carlsen you don't want to capture here
you simply on double call since pawns
and then you're really losing the game
a four we have King to g7 Carson gets
his King into the game as this is the
end game you do have to play with your
king b5 now a capture some b5 a capture
some b5 and of course totally not
capturing on b5 now about getting the
King deeper into the position B captures
and c6 b captures on c6 and now rook to
a3 Tingler anot wants to somehow get his
rook into the game via the a file c5r up
to d3 now attacking the d5 pawn h3 would
check King to g1 and rook to d6
defending and again Carlson is still up
two pawns he still down the exchange but
doesn't really matter this C pawn is a
monster
this Knight is you know it looks like
it's more useful than these rooks so
rook to d1 King goes deeper into the
position rook to be two now c4 rook to
b8 and a c3 now as the knight on e4 is
protecting the c3 pawn now this is a
this is a monster passed pawn rook to f8
check King 35 rook to e8 check rope the
e6 now offering the exchange of rooks of
course Eliran cannot accept this as he
would just lose the game I wrote back to
the 8th now again rub the d6 rook back
to e8 with check and now Carson doesn't
want to repeat since you know a
threefold threefold repetition is a
thing King to f5 rook to f8 and now King
te6 rook to e8 check and our King today
7 the rook has to move and now Knight to
d2 blocking the attack of this rook to
the to the d5 pawn rook to c1 attacking
the pawn now rook the c6 defending with
the rook rook to a3
Knight goes back to e4 route goes back
to d1 but now King goes back to e6
and now there are no more no more checks
from this rook so this was a shrewd
maneuvering by Carlsen rook the c1 we
have Brooke to b6 now rook captures on
c3 and heerd England decided to give
back the exchange
because there there is no clear plan
here for white at some point if he
doesn't capture the pawn carlson will
play rook to be to get his king here
push the pawn and with night to d2 it's
it's gonna be very hard to defend this
for white and it was a 10 minute game so
rook captures and c3 Knight captures and
rook captures so now England is only
down one point and it's a rooks ending
but the position is too much in
Carlson's favor is called an immediately
placed rook to me one would check
forcing illyrians king to h2 and now
rook the f1 a beautiful move really a
nice rook endgame move as the king the
King can't approach the rook upon its
covering G two rooks covering g1 and the
cousin is threatening to capture the f2
pawn so the rook has to protect the pawn
rook to c2 and now as this rook is
forced the protected DF to point across
and King is free to wander about and
finish the game rook to be too kinky for
rook a to this rook can never leave the
second-ranked now King to f3
the threat is rook captures an f2 with
Czech exchanging groups and winning the
game so add England tries for maybe
maybe Carlson will blunder and this was
this is actually a great opportunity to
blunder the game as if you play rook
captures an f2 would check rook captures
King captures you get E 5 and although
you're up to pawns you're still not
gonna win this game
d 4 e 6 d 3 e 7 d 2 now
leerin brings in the Queen Carlsen
brings out his queen but the problem is
Eliran has Queen III would to check
sacrificing the Queen and if you capture
the Queen it's a stalemate
unfortunately the whitening has nowhere
to go and if you don't capture if you
play something like King to f1 now we
get Queen have to check sacrificing the
Queen and f2 and it's a forced stalemate
so after E 4 of course Carlsen didn't
blunder he's not you know world champion
without a reason he played King
characters on e4 rook to e2 with check
now King to d3
rook to e3 would check and after
King to see for the game is over
dinkler and resigned in this position
there is nothing for him to do this rook
is ready to capture an f2 you can't
protect it with rook to eat or rook to
f3 yeah but it doesn't matter whatever
you play Carson is simply gonna play d4
D 3 D 1 and you know destroy so yeah
after D Ford England resigned the game
and sorry after after King C 4 and
England resigned the game and this is it
for the 10-minute section now probably
right about at the moment that I upload
this video they will start the 5 minute
portion with 12 games so it's it's gonna
be quite quite the end of the match I'm
interesting I'm interested to see if
Carson can can manage can keep this up
as in all three sections so far the
England only achieved one and a half
point in each section and won only one
game so and I also read one interesting
thing that if Carson would achieve this
kind of result in the next 12 games he
would actually break the 3000 rating
barrier but unfortunately fidei rules do
not allow this because he already won
the match so the rest of the match I
guess isn't it doesn't count for rating
or I could be wrong but I did I did read
read something like this maybe some of
you know something more about this so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it it was a bit of a longer
video for you know for a rapid game but
you know these players are very strong
and they play a very strong game it
doesn't matter if you just give him 10
minutes so that's it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
all for watching and I will see you soon
maybe maybe with another game from the
champions showdown in st. Louis see you
soon